This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Today we have an incredibly special episode. I've invited on two of my friends who run their own podcast, Who Broke Chicks, to discuss relationships.
I think on this show, as someone who is single, we only really talk about the beginnings and the ends, the dating or the breakup. But today we're going to talk about something a little bit more nuanced, which is how our relationships, particularly our romantic relationships in our 20s, interact with our identity and how to maintain our identities in a relationship. So welcome, Sal and Al. How are you both going?
I'm excited. I'm so excited. I'm good. Hello. We are so happy to be here. And we're big fans of Gem and this show. So it's just a match made in heaven. Also, Gem, you have such a beautiful.
voice. I like was getting like hypnotized almost there in the intro. Thank you. Now I'm feeling something else. A little ASMR episode for everyone. Seriously. We're probably like a really harsh difference for everyone. Well I think they need that. Also I love when people from Australia come on the show because a lot of the time I have people from the US or the UK. So now they can hear three Australian accents. Yeah, you're blight again. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Go on, we're going to talk about laugh. Took my Sheila to the pub the other day and got her a beer and now we're dating. Got her a shnitty and I said, do you want to be me, girl?
Now she's my missus. Yeah, we have a trademark term on our show called the Hornie Sheila. Yeah, it's us. Yeah, that's the energy that we project. Well, I love that and thank you for bringing that energy to the show today. So the thing that was really interesting to me when I was thinking about this topic is that we are all in very different stages of the relationship spectrum. So I am single as a pringle. Except for I just get a DM from a certain someone.
Someone's feeling a bit of a smitten kitten. I am a bit of a smitten kitten. I'm so cute. Thanks guys. Yeah, but we all know how good that message feels. Like when you have like that crush or you like someone and then they send you a message and you're like, you literally just float. for the rest of the day. It really is. I've been floated
for the last like 10 minutes. So basically I'm almost in a new relationship. I'm actually thinking a spring wedding. Not native floral arrangements. Yes, of course. So anyhow, no, I'm very single, have been for over a year.
But I did start this podcast after a pretty serious breakup. So that's where this whole concept came from. You have just, you've recently entered into a new relationship. So I was single for about three years, before that I was in relationships for about five years. Wow. And then, yeah, had, I think what I felt was I was very attached to the identity that I got back
in that three years of being single and the effort that I had to put into rebuilding that identity. And we can get into a bit later, but how I felt like I lost my identity in those earlier relationships and then the effort that it took to feel like me again really kind of deterred me from getting into a relationship that I was like I don't I don't need anyone like I got in that head space of I don't need anyone I'm so happy being single so like good doing me and like I would date and you know and then I would have moments of being like oh do I want a relationship and then I met my now partner and I was like oh shit he's a really good one and I was like yeah
I like you. And so then now I'm kind of like in that phase. So we've been dating for about nine months now. So it's still quite early. But I think we've gone through that like honeymoon period. And it's just really nice. But also how do I navigate from being so independent and single to being in like the most perfect relationship ever?
It's like a very steady relationship even though it is so new. Relatively new. I'm like, and also I'm the queen of self-sabotage sometimes. So like there'd be moments and like I'd be talking to sound. She'd be like, you don't need to do this. I literally would say you were trying to ruin this. Like you were self-sabotaging right now in this moment. Stop it.
You need a friend like that sometimes. And that's because Sal is a guru. A guru. Yeah, I've been in a relationship with my partner, Chris, for almost 15 years. So it'll be 15 years in August. She's a veteran. And how did you meet him? We met on MySpace.
On MySpace? Yes, literally. Wow. So we were both like two little emoes when we were teenagers slash I never grew out of it. It was never a phase mom. But we met through mutual friends from going to gigs and whatnot. But he added me on MySpace and that's how we actually met. Wow.
And then we just like hung out from from there. Wow. That's a beautiful story. to little in-roar kids meet on my space. That's a good one to tell. And I think that it's very interesting that we're all sitting here with different perspectives to discuss what we really want to discuss today, which is how do you maintain your identity in a relationship?
Because our romantic relationships are a massive facet of our lives, particularly in our 20s, but within every period, I think that this is the time when a lot of us start to, contemplate the idea of a life partner, we start to date around, we start to have standards and most of us are in... Start to have steamy. Start to start being the operative word. Yeah. Right, fun. Yeah. Well, that's my, honestly, I feel like that's my, my experience where I've, like, hit my, like, mid-20s and I'm like, all righty. So, like, early mid-20s and been like, okay, now, like, dating is, it's still fun, but it's not something that I'm doing impulsively
because I now understand that the person I'm with is going to create a large part of how I see myself and how I see my life and my future plans. So how did you think that transition for you was out? because you came from where I am now, you know, from a very, from a place of almost hyper independence, it sounds like, and then suddenly had to adapt to having this other person in your life. And you said there was a bit of self-sabotage going on. Yeah, I think so.
Yeah. I think I, so when I entered my single girl era, I was definitely not independent. I definitely relied on my relationships. to kind of keep me entertained, kind of, I pulled a lot of worse from them in terms of myself because my first relationship, I was independent, but that person relied on me a lot. That, like, I was that person's universe and that was a lot of pressure. My second relationship, I went to, like, the other end of the spectrum that I was like,
I want someone who doesn't even shit about me that just, like, has their own life. And then that was like, and then it was the other end of the spectrum. And I was like, wait, no, like, love me. And so then I kind of had this, this tugger war internally of, you know, not really knowing what I wanted or who I was because I kind of molded myself to these people and what they needed or what they didn't give me. And so then when I was single, I really had to kind of go back and figure out who I was, what I wanted and what I enjoyed just by myself.
Like first, that first thing's first. I don't think you can know who your identity is in a relationship until you understand who that identity is, as our Lord and Savior, Rupal says, if you don't love yourself, how the hell are you going to love somebody else? And I didn't love myself. I didn't have that. And it took a really long time to build that up and, you know, your friends is a really big part of that. Having, being able to be comfortable on your own is a really big part of that. And in those three years, I had so much, much fun, like the best time. And kind of what you were saying before, that for a good chunk of that time, it was dating for the story, it was dating for fun and just living life and realizing
things, as Kylie Jenna said in 2016. Wow, flashback. She has her sources. Yeah, she has her references 2016 at all. You can check that. Actually, I saw the video the other day and that is the year. And In that time, I experienced so many new things. I literally changed my sexuality in that time. Like, I experimented with girls and realized that, hey, do you know what? It's probably a bit weird to continue scissoring your Barbies at 16 years old. But I'm just kidding. I wasn't doing that.
But I would always kind of feel like that. Be like, oh, like, do I like girls? I was like, I don't know. Like, I could kiss them. And I'm like, you're gay. Like, come on. Like you're trying to convince yourself. And then you finally gave yourself the freedom to be like, let me embrace this with no label.
Yeah. And so then I think when I got to the point that I was like, okay, this is me. Like I know what my identity is because it's so hard if you don't know what that is to not mold yourself to the person that you start dating. And you start molding yourself to their likes and their dislikes. And it's so important to keep your likes and dislikes, even if you're. if that's not compatible to the other person. So I think what was different about, you know, this relationship that I'm in now was that I had the confidence to just be myself.
I had the confidence to be like, well, if you don't like it, that's fine, because I like me. And you don't want to date someone that doesn't like you. Like there's so often, I once had a boyfriend turn around to me and say, yeah, I love you, just sometimes I don't like you. I know. And I laughed. Like I thought it was funny.
And now I look back and I'm like, that was really mean. That was cruel. Well, Al-in I were having this conversation yesterday about how that is a real trope in relationships. Like guys being like, oh, like we've got the, you know, I'm out with the boys like free of the ball on chain or, you know, like people speak about their partners like that. And it's like, no, you should actually like each other and there should be joy there and you should want to spend time with them. It's weird. That is so weird to me. And I think that it's honestly a hard thing to learn your own worth, especially having been
through experiences like that. Like I know that I have as well. This person that I dated like probably two years ago, I became a completely different person for them. I sacrificed friendships for that person and I regret it all the time. Like I still to this day, I don't think about him much except for the choices that I would definitely not make again. And it's interesting because then recently I had a very similar incident, like a very similar experience with someone where the exact same situation happened. And I remember
sitting there and being like, I have two choices here. Do I do the thing that I've done before? Do I make that mistake again? Or I've learnt this lesson, let's go the other way. And I went the other way. And I think that that's a big part of how relationships can also form you as they teach you these important lessons that then you can take to not just your next relationship, but your friendships and your morals and your values. I do want to quickly ask you a question because I'm fascinated by this. I genuinely am because I imagine the person I was dating when I was like in my teen years and I saw this TikTok the other day and it was like, would you rather still be working your first job? but would you rather still be with the person you were dating when you were 17? Oh my God. Right?
I said I totally was like, boost juice, I'm coming back. Like, I'm making those mango magics for the rest of my life. Taylor's Petisserie, give me those cinnamon donuts again. I'm down. Yeah. Those both sound like great choices. Also, boost juice, amazing. Oh, yeah.
Can I get a tropical crush please? A mango magic please? Oh my goodness. No, no. I'm out of office. But I guess the question is, what has that been like? you and I know that you've gotten a lot of um sometimes people have said to you like don't you wish you have tried a few more try before you buy or tried a few more people or like gone out there
and had that single girl era that you were just talking about out and what would be your response to that so I think at first I really did question if that was something that I should be doing and was like oh like am I I was I've always been happy in my relationship but questions like that made me wonder if is it just because this is all I've known, do I need to go out and explore something else? But I think the response that I give people now is that over the last 15 years, there's never been one time where I've interacted with anyone that made me even question my relationship or tempted me. Excuse me, I'm sitting right here. Aside from you out, you're the one ally. Thank you. But yeah, I just like, I just try to listen to my gut.
and like what I want to do, I'm the sort of person that if you tell me to do something, I'll probably just do the exact opposite out of spite. So I, yeah, I don't know. I was like, what, and be like you guys? Like, it doesn't really seem like any of my friends were having heaps of fun during that say. Do you know what I mean, though? We were not. We are not.
Well, not you guys specifically. I mean the people that were asking me this question. Because a lot of the time when that's getting projected on you, I think it is maybe coming from a place of insecurity in some instances being like, yeah, but don't you want to be single? Because that might be a little bit of more of them reaching for a bit of comfortability being like, yeah, but it's good to be single. It's good.
Like, I'm enjoying this. So that reassurance that is like, oh, but I'm good for being in this position that maybe looking at someone, it is when you are single, you look at people in relationships. And sometimes you are like, oh, thank God, I'm not in a relationship. like he can do all this fun stuff i can do whatever i want to do and then sometimes you are like that would be nice yeah and i think what is so the way that you and chris and like well i feel like i've learned from you guys as well now in a new relationship is that you only have so much energy to give in life and that's got to be split across work friends your own time your hobbies and then you add a
partner into that. And so you've only got like a hundred percent of a tank. So if you're splitting that, you know, 25 percent against across like work, friends, your own time and then your hobbies, you've then got to take that time away from something. And because you need to obviously invest time in a relationship, but what can often happen is people pull all of that 25 percent that split across everything and they put 100 percent into that relationship. And that's, a mistake that I'd made in the past and that's something that I've never seen you do so and like the way that it's been so important and it's an effort to do because when you do meet someone that you really like and you do enter that relationship you are the most smitten kitten
you're like I'm obsessed with this person I want to smell their neck every day like literally I'm like oh that's good stuff oh my god yeah and like you are obsessed with them and that's so good like keep that but be obsessed with them in like moderation have nights away from each other have those moments that like you allow yourselves to miss each other a little bit and it's so important that you don't pull all the like reserve energy in other tanks and put it into that one because what happens if that doesn't work out yeah I totally no no no no but I was just and like I think as well communicating and holding down the fort on your wants your enjoyments on what you had when you were single is really important.
Like, we talk about this all the time on two broke cheeks, but I love a smutty fairy book. Like, it's just my happy place in my little fantasy land with two enemies to lovers. And it's just the best art. The best trope ever. And like we went on holidays and maybe for like two or three hours of the day, we'd just go and do our own thing. Like we weren't spending the whole day together because I'd want to
to go read my book for like an hour or maybe go for a walk or he'd want to go like do something. I don't know what boys do in their own time. He's like a big YouTube watch us. He would like just want to go watch YouTube and just like turn off for a bit like that. And we would just go spend time on our own doing our own wants or whenever there's a thing like, I'm like, oh yeah, I'm going to go stay at sales. He's just like, okay. There's never like, oh, but I'm going to miss you so much.
Don't go. Or if we do say that, we don't mean it. Like if I'm like, oh, you're going to the gym, he's like, yeah, and I'm like, no, stay in bed. And then he's like, do you want me to? And there's like that thing of being like, I will if you really want. And I'm like, no, no, no, no, go. Like, just having your own things that you do and not losing that because it is really easy to. Yeah.
I agree. And I think that the mistake I've made in past relationships is when you spend every waking minute together, every night, especially in those early, that early period. like where you that's like where all the bonding happens when you when you conflate all of that oxytocin and that dopamine with the other person's presence you become codependent but additionally all of that time and all of that codependency I honestly think just speeds up the timeline of the relationship if it's not the right one 100 it puts it under so much pressure
because you need time to breathe you need time to receive stimulation from your friends from your family, from your hobbies, and when you don't allow the relationship to breathe, when you put in a pressure cooker and you like almost join your hands together and won't let them go, all that's going to do is just completely just burn the string out. And you'll be, you'll be done by the end of the week. You'll get bored. You'll get bored. And you start irritating each other. Yeah. Like you will get to like the point that you're just like, the sound of their voice makes me want to cry. And it's. Yeah. And then.
as well you start sitting there and thinking how do we get here like i was so in love with you how we it's because like you do need to give that breather you need to have that time that you're investing in other things because as well you're the only constant in your own life i so agree with that you can't rely on anyone else to be your social life to be like the one solo person to be your social life your happiness your entertainment like you need to be that for yourself and then you you need to pull on multiple resources for that. You need to have your friends. You need to have your, like, I say work, but when I say work,
I mean that thing that fuels you and makes you feel successful. Yeah. And then your partner can also feed into that. But it's so important to have those multiple energy sources that isn't just one person because that energy source, if it is just that one person, will run out. Yeah, that's like draining on both of you. And also, when you're in a relationship, you're supposed to be growing together but also individually.
And if you don't each have your own individual things going on, there's nothing new to bring to the relationship. Like there's no points of conversation. There's no like, oh, I learned this or I had this experience and sharing that because it's like, oh, wait, you were there. So then you just become stagnant. And I think that's bad for both you as an individual but also the relationship. There's just nowhere to go from there.
And I wanted to ask, because you live with your partner, Chris now. Yeah. Did you have any of those fears of spending so much time together when you first moved in? Yeah, a little bit. So we've lived together for I think like six years now, but for the first seven or eight years, I'm bad at maths, of our relationship. I think that's right. Yeah. We were almost in a long distance relationship because he lived about an hour and a half away from me when we first started dating. Then I moved up to Sydney and we lived three hours away. So we would only get to spend weekends together pretty much. So to go from that to then living together, I was a little bit concerned and I also know that like I love socialising. I love going to gigs.
I love to go out and have like a night out with the girls. Chris doesn't drink. So there's differences in our lifestyles that I was like, okay, this will be interesting. But I really had faith that we that it was going to be great. And I was like, this is actually going to be so fun. It's really going to bring us together. But a lot of other people were saying, this is going to be a real test for your relationship. And again, like, I feel like my gut instinct was like,
no, this is going to be a good thing. Like, we've been dating for many years by this point. Like, I would hope that I know him well enough that I think this is going to work. And it did. Like, I think, and I think it's because we have maintained those separate, like separation in our lives. So, you know, he has his own group of friends that he'll hang out with. We have our own hobbies. We have both very different careers, but are both very supportive
of each other's work lives and are still like best friends at the end of the day also. And we have a lot of fun together. And I think that's the thing is we have like joy and laughter every single day that we will go one day without each other. And I like, am genuinely so. excited to go home and see him. Oh, that's so amazing. I think one thing as well that like we both do in our relationships is we are not constantly talking throughout the day. Like we'll have like a few texts maybe of communication with our partners through the day. Well, sometimes we don't talk to them at all. But it's like there is no constant thread of communication throughout the whole day, especially if you live together. That's so much because then you do see each other and you're
like, oh, so what is, what are we talking about? Yeah. Because I've already told you everything the second is happening that like constant texting constant needs like call every hour and check in and talk about what's happening in your day like isn't healthy because again what is there what more do you have or if you're watching every single TV show together or doing every single hobby together you've got nothing to like you're like oh I watch this really cool movie oh you watch it too yeah like yes you've gotten there's no spice yeah yeah And just no time to enjoy things on your own and what you like. You'll just end up watching Wall Street.
Well, American Psycho. Yeah. And it's like those points of difference, right? And I loved what you said before about almost diversifying your portfolio, your life portfolio, because I do think that there's a tendency that I've seen in myself and amongst friends where a new love interest enters, suddenly 60% it carved off to them. And it's natural to be obsessed. It's natural to have all of that, all of those things like rushing in your brain and rushing
through your body and like pulling you towards that person. But the big thing that I think often loses out is our friendships. I think that is the first thing to go because you need work for money. I think hobbies are another one that sometimes we let go of pretty quickly. But I do think that we have a dedicated like social time. And sometimes we see social time as like, romantic time and they they take from each other so how how did you what either of you can answer this question like would you have any advice for how to maintain healthy good friendships whilst in a
relationship especially in those early days because I think it's the worst thing to spend the first six months obsessed with someone wake up things aren't going great and you don't have any friends yeah yeah I think at the start and by at the start I'm talking like the first month. I think it's okay to be like completely infatuated with the person. I think your friends especially good ones will sit there and watch and be like, love this for you because they've also probably been there while you're dating absolute trash. And they're like, please don't get back with your ex.
So when you actually meet someone good, they're like, stick, stick, stick, stay. This is an autobiographical conversation. Yeah. So I think it's actually okay. to be guiltless about falling in love. I think you shouldn't have to stress yourself out about being like, I've met this person. I really want to spend time with them this weekend,
but I don't know, do I have to see like the girls, like blah, blah, blah. That's okay, you can do that. But once, you know, after a month, you definitely need to make sure that you're investing in your friendships in that month. Also, don't fall off the face of the earth. Like keep up communications
and don't just speak about yourself. don't just speak about how happy you are and how amazing things are. Definitely speak to it. But not only about that, make sure that you're asking and investing in your friends' lives as well. I think what I've actually kind of found it a lot simpler in this relationship than others because I like missing my partner. I like having time away and building that.
And it is hard because when you are completely infatuated, then you're like, I just want to spend every second with you. but I've burned that bridge before. Like I've done that and I'm like, I know I don't want that. Plus, I'm also infatuated with my friends.
So I think having those really good quality friends that you do genuinely feed off and want to see and booking in those times, like have the girls night that you're like, oh my God, I saw this really cool bar. Let's all go on Friday and go. You're going on Friday. And it's not a chore.
You're not like, oh, I've got to go see my friends. If you feel like that, maybe that's something to investigate further too. It's not the relationship's fault. Yeah, it's not the relationship's fault if you're like dreading seeing your friends. And so I think making sure that you invest time into doing things that you really want to do and booking it in if you are kind of struggling, if you do have a partner that wants to spend that Friday night with you as well, making sure that you let them know in advance being like,
你不会觉得，哦，我得去见我的朋友了。如果你有这种感觉，也许这也值得去进一步探究。这不是这段关系的问题。是的，如果你害怕去见朋友，那不是这段关系的问题。所以我觉得，要确保你投入时间去做自己真正想做的事，如果有点吃力的话就把时间预约好，如果你确实有一个也想和你一起度过周五晚上的伴侣，一定要提前让他们知道，比如：
by the way, on Friday, like I'm going to this bar with the girls. You're not asking for permission, by the way, we don't do that. We don't be like, is that okay? You'll just be like, I'm not available, I'm doing this. And they'll be like, stunning, amazing brave. That's literally what Chris and I do at the beginning of every week on like a Sunday night. We're like, all right, so what's the schedule for this week? And I'm like, okay, so I'll be home this night, this night.
顺便说一下，周五我要和闺蜜去这家酒吧。顺便说一句，你不是在征求许可，我们不那样做。我们不会说什么“这样可以吗？”你只会说：“我没空，我要去这儿。”他们就会觉得：“哇，太棒了，太勇敢了。”这字面意思就是克里斯和我每周初在周日晚上做的事情。我们会说：“好吧，那这周的日程是什么？”然后我就说：“好的，所以这天晚上、这天晚上我会回家。”
And he's like, okay, cool. Like I'm meeting up with friends on this night. I'm going to do this on this night. And we're like, okay, great. So Friday we'll go on a date then. And do it like that. But I think, yeah, like booking in regular catch-ups with your girlfriends and don't invite your fucking boyfriend.
然后他说：“好的，酷。这天晚上我要去见朋友。这天晚上我要去做这个。”然后我们就会说：“好，太棒了。那周五我们去约会吧。”就这样安排。但我认为，是的，比如和闺蜜们定期约聚，而且千万别带上你那该死的男朋友。
Sorry, I don't know if I can swear on the show. You can totally swear. That does not count. I think a lot of people think that counts. Like, no, but we caught up last weekend. Jason was there, so it doesn't count. And people are different when their partners are there. You can't talk about the gross little things that you do with the girls
抱歉，我不知道我能不能在节目里说脏话。你完全可以爆粗口。那个不算。我觉得很多人以为那个算。比如，不，但我们上周末刚聚过。杰森也在，所以那不算。而且当伴侣在场时，人们的表现是不一样的。你不能和闺蜜谈论那些恶心的小事
when you're like, oh my God, guys, I ate this through the other day. And literally what came out of me was not humanly possible. Like, you can't talk about that when, like, it's just different and like because maybe you're comfortable to say them in front of your boyfriend but your friend probably doesn't want to talk about the giant poo they did yeah yeah your boyfriend so like don't bring them and that's an important part of French yeah talking about like you're on a cruise and I think one thing that is kind of easy for me and mine is that a lot of my friends like my friends and my boyfriend's friends had mutual friends so like when we're
当你觉得，哦天哪，伙计们，我前几天吃了这个。然后从我身体里排出来的东西简直不是人类能做到的。比如，当有伴侣在时，你就不能谈论那个，因为……就是感觉不一样，而且也许你在男朋友面前说这些觉得很自在，但你的朋友可能不想讨论他们拉的巨大粪便，对吧，对吧？还有你的男朋友，所以别带他们来，那是女性友谊的重要部分，对，谈论就像你在游轮上一样。而且我觉得对我跟我男朋友来说比较简单的一点是，我的很多朋友，比如我的朋友和我男朋友的朋友有共同的朋友，所以当我们
kind of spending time in a group atmosphere, it is very easy. But what happens is like, he'll go off with like a group of people and then I'll chill with like another group that we don't need to be attached to the hip in those like social settings. Like we can go to a party and be like, okay, Dils is see you in two hours. And that's fine. And I love that. I've had partners that like glued to my hip at an event and I was like, get off me. And it's a lot. But I was going somewhere with this. Oh yeah. Like we recently went on a cruise with our group of friends and some of them are in relationships and then some of them are single and so it can be like a cruise there's not a lot of pickings for singles and so then anyway one of them
在群体的氛围中度过时间时，非常简单。但情况是，他会和一群人一起走开，然后我会和另一群人放松，在那些社交场合中我们不需要形影不离。我们可以去参加一个派对，然后说：“好的，迪尔斯，两小时后见。”这完全没问题。我很喜欢这样。我以前的伴侣在活动中就像黏在我屁股后面一样，当时我就想：“离我远点。”这太粘人了。不过我刚才正说到某个地方。哦对。就像我们最近和一群朋友去了一次游轮旅行，他们中有的人在谈恋爱，有些则是单身，所以可能会像游轮上那样，单身人士的选择并不多，然后无论如何其中一个
I was like let's just do a girl's night like let's like ditch the boys for one night and just hang out with the girls like making sure that you're kind of showing up for your friendships not just booking it in when it's convenient for you like not being like oh I'm free on Friday night, why don't we get a drink then? Definitely, that's amazing. But making sure that if they're being like, oh, I don't have anything on this weekend, do you want to hang out? Like, you're going. Like, even if maybe you were planning on just having a movie night with your partner, if you don't have like the most concrete of plans, making sure that you're still showing up for your friends, especially friends that you were,
我就说：“我们办个闺蜜之夜吧，比如我们为了一个晚上把男生们甩掉，只和闺蜜们一起闲逛。”确保你不仅在对自己方便时才去维护友情，不是那种觉得“哦，我周五晚上有空，我们那天去喝一杯怎么样？”当然，那太棒了。而是要确保如果他们说“哦，我这周末没事，你想出去玩吗？”你就去。即使你可能原本只打算和伴侣过个电影之夜，如果你没有最具体、最确定的计划，也要确保你依然在为朋友们出席，特别是那些……
like, your single girlie with. Yeah. Because for them, you don't want them to feel abandoned. Yeah. That it's like, they're like, well, we used to spend all this time. together we used to go out and you know pick up and flirt and just or just hang out together and then you don't want them to feel like you've just run off found a boyfriend and their jobs done like they serve their purpose you don't want them to feel that way yeah so making sure that you still show up for them whenever they do want to go out and have that fun time that you're there I really agree with this as someone who is single right now um that's something that I have found it's almost something that you dread like your friends get into a new relationship and you're like
比如，你的单身好闺蜜。是的。因为对于她们来说，你不会想让她们觉得被抛弃了。是的。因为她们会觉得，嗯，我们以前花那么多时间在一起，我们以前一起出去，你知道的，去搭讪、调情，或者只是在一起闲逛，然后你不会想让她们觉得你刚跑开、找了个男朋友，她们的任务就完成了，觉得她们失去了价值。你不会想让她们有这种感觉，是的。所以确保当她们想出去玩、享受那种欢乐时光时，你依然为她们出现，你在那里。作为一个目前单身的人，我非常赞同这一点，嗯，这是我发现的一种情况，这几乎是一种你会感到害怕的事——你的朋友进入了一段新恋情，然后你会想
alright so am i about to be like the third fourth option now or is this going to is this going to stay the same and you have to i think appreciate from the other perspective that like you said when your friend someone you love is going through this incredible experience you do really want to be there you do want to be happy for them but additionally i do think that sometimes i've had experiences where friends have gotten into relationships and it's been impossible to get a hold of them. And you just feel a little bit like it wasn't authentic that what you had.
好吧，我是不是要变成第三、第四顺位了？还是说这种情况、这种情况会保持不变？你必须，我觉得要从另一个角度去理解，就像你说的，当你爱的人经历这段不可思议的经历时，你确实真的很想支持他们，你确实想为他们感到高兴。但另外，我确实觉得有时我有过这样的经历：朋友谈了恋爱，结果根本联系不上他们。你就会觉得你们之间曾经拥有的东西有点不够真实。
You feel like you've been dumped. Yeah, you do. You feel like you've been replaced. And you're like, hey, what about me? Yeah, and it's the interesting thing. Like, I love your point about, I think if you are, from the perspective of someone who has, like a lot of my friends are in long-term relationships now,
你觉得自己被甩了。是的，确实如此。你觉得自己被取代了。然后你会想：“嘿，那我呢？”是的，这是一件很有意思的事情。我特别喜欢你关于……我觉得如果你处于那种角度，从一个身边有很多朋友现在都在长期恋爱关系中的人的视角来看——
please don't invite your partner unless they are explicitly invited. I have one of my best friends I, her and her partner and I are actually friends so, but we met through her but and I don't mind if he's around like because I actually, if she goes away like she will go out and go shopping and he'll like stay at my place and like
请不要带上你的伙伴，除非他们被明确邀请了。我有一个最好的朋友，我、她和她的伴侣其实也是朋友，所以，但我们是通过她认识的，我不介意他在场，因为实际上，如果她离开，比如她会出去逛街，他会待在我这儿，然后
we'll just like have tea and chat or like that's not a problem but the thing is that she does a good job at being like all right bug her off her and I are going to hang out for a little bit and there is an understanding there that your your friendships play an equally important part in your well-being as your relationships. 1,000%. And I kind of also hate that notion that like there's something bad about being single. Like, I don't know about you if you've ever experienced this, but when I was, like, people in
我们就喝喝茶聊聊天，或者说这都不是问题。但关键在于，她把这件事做得很好，会说：“好啦，让她走开，她和我今天要单独逛一会儿。”并且彼此有一种默契，即你的友谊在你的幸福中扮演着与你的恋爱关系同等重要的角色。百分之千。而且我也挺讨厌那种认为单身有什么不好的说法的。我不知道你有没有过这种经历，但当我单身时，处在
relationship would be like, oh, like, don't worry, you'll find someone. And you're like, I'm not looking. Oh, my gosh. You know what I hate? Sorry, guys, I'm going to, I'm steering the ship in a new direction. I want to ask this question of you to, both of you being in relationship. relationships, the thing I get all the time, and I'm not looking for love. I already found it. No, just me. He's already here. No, I'm not.
恋爱关系中的人就会说：“哦，别担心，你会找到另一半的。”而你会说：“我根本没在找。”天哪。你知道我讨厌什么吗？抱歉，伙计们，我要把船开向一个新的方向。我想对你们两个身处恋爱关系中的人问这个问题。我经常遇到的情况是，我并没有在寻找爱。我已经找到了。不，只有我。他已经在这里了。不，我没有。
I'm so busy that it's not possible. But the thing that people always say to me is it will happen when you least expect it. And I find that so frustrating because, oh, it will happen when you're not looking for it. If you are an anxious person, like we all are at some stages, you are never not looking for the next thing around the corner. That's the whole point about like anticipatory anxiety. So was that true for you both? Did it happen when you were least expecting it or when you when you stopped looking?
我太忙了，这根本不可能。但人们总是对我说的一句话是，当你最意想不到的时候，它就会发生。我觉得这太令人沮丧了，因为，哦，当你没有在寻找它的时候，它就会发生。如果你是一个焦虑的人，就像我们在某些阶段所有人一样，你永远不会停止寻找转角处的下一件事。这就是预期焦虑的全部意义。所以这对你们俩来说是真的吗？它是发生在你最意想不到的时候，还是当你停止寻找的时候？
No. No? Not at all. Like I feel like I'd gone from like dating like little like high school fuck boys and basically learning exactly what I didn't want. And then was talking to one guy who I really thought that I really liked and then met and then was just like, well, that's over now. Like, so it wasn't even like, oh, like I'm not going to date. I'm just going to, it's like, no, I was looking.
没有。没有？完全没有。我觉得我之前经历过跟高中那些渣男约会，基本上清楚了自己究竟不想要什么。然后和其中一个我真心以为自己挺喜欢的男生聊过，接着见面了，然后就觉得，好吧，现在这已经结束了。所以甚至都不是那种“哦，我不会去约会了，我只是要去……”而是，不，我一直在找。
Yeah. I think mine's like a bit of both. I think I was like in my sexy single girl era and had taken the time to work on myself that like there were definitely times that I was like, I'm not looking for a relationship. I was like, absolutely not. I'm so good doing me because I was working on myself. I was having that time. and was very problematically still engaging with an ex.
是的。我觉得我的情况两者兼有。我觉得我当时处于性感单身女孩的时代，花时间提升自我，所以确实有好几次我会觉得：“我不需要一段感情。”我当时想：“绝对不。我一个人过得很好。”因为我在自我提升。我在享受那段时光，
No, you weren't. That's so bad. It's so boring too. I'm sure you had something to say about that. Yeah, this is the self-sabotaging part that she's talking about. Whilst you've had... No, no, no, no. I was like, wait, that's a bold thing to admit.
不，你没有。这太糟糕了。这也太无聊了。我确信你对这个有什么想说的。是的，这就是她所说的自我破坏。当你有过……不，不，不，不。我当时想，等等，承认这个太大胆了。
No, no, no. Or like months before I met my partner. Like nearly a year before I met my partner. Yeah. And like we still had contact. And then it got to a point that I was like, like I can't move on like I can't move on properly like I definitely was not emotionally still there like I was not in love with this person anymore but it was a crutch and I was like oh
不，不，不。或者在我遇到伴侣的几个月前。差不多在我遇到伴侣的前一年。是的。而且我们依然有联系。然后到了某个时刻，我发现自己无法继续前行，无法真正地继续前行，我显然在情感上还没有彻底放下，我虽然不再爱这个人了，但它成了一种精神拐杖，然后我想：
you know what this is not feeding me anymore and I was like this is done and if I want to actually find someone that I want to be with then I'm cutting this person off and that's exactly what I did and then a year later, I actually met my partner. And it wasn't, like, planned I met them through mutual friends. So, like, that is kind of the way that, like, I wasn't expecting it. But once I met them, I was like, yeah, I was like, this is, but it's only because I kind of shut off the things that was holding me back from being in a relationship. Like, I was like, okay, I'm not going to engage with things that kind of stunt me emotionally.
你知道吗，这再也无法滋养我了，我觉得这一切都结束了。如果我真的想找一个我想与之共度一生的人，那我必须跟这个人断绝联系。这正是我所做的。然后一年后，我真的遇到了我的伴侣。这并不是什么计划好的，我是通过共同的朋友认识他的。所以，这可以说是那种……我并没有期待它发生。但一旦我遇见了他，我就会觉得，是的，这就是……但这只是因为我切断了那些阻碍我进入一段感情的事情。当时我想，好吧，我不会再与那些在情感上阻碍我成长的事情纠缠。
and I felt like I had that time to myself that I was like, cool, I feel like I know who I am, that I'm actually confident to get into a relationship if I feel like it's going to be the right one. And then, like, he came out of the blue. Like, I had no idea who he was. I'd never met him before. And he was amazing. So I was like, well, shit. But I was also very scared of commitment because I'd been burned.
我觉得我有了属于自己的时间，当时我想：太好了，我觉得我了解自己是谁，如果我觉得合适的话，我其实有信心进入一段感情。然后，他突然就出现了。我根本不知道他是谁。我以前从来没见过他。而且他太棒了，所以我就想，好吧，见鬼。但我也非常害怕承诺，因为我曾受过伤害。
So I, like, had to navigate. that when we first met, like, I would take like a week to reply. Like the first date I bailed on. No way. Yeah. He bailed on it. I bailed on the first day. And he came and he asked him for another?
所以，当我们刚见面时，我不得不去处理那种情绪，比如我需要花一周时间才回复。第一次约会我甚至放了鸽子。不会吧。是的。他放了我鸽子。我放了第一次约会的鸽子。然后他走过来，又向我发出第二次约会邀请？
Or did you reschedule? I ended up messaging him because I was like, because he, the night we met, he ended up like booking a date. He was like, we're going on a date. And I was like, I got like that first date anxiety. And then I was also sick. He doesn't believe me. But I genuinely was.
还是你改期了？我最后给他发了信息，因为我觉得……因为他，我们相遇的那天晚上，最后预订了一次约会。他说：“我们要去约会。”然后我就有了那种第一次约会的焦虑。而且当时我也生病了。他不相信我。但我确实是真的生病了。
She was. She was. I was. I was. But I was also like, I know where they go. I think the first date, anxiety definitely still played a part, but she was genuinely sick. I was genuinely sick. I have the antibiotics prescription to prove it.
她确实病了。她确实病了。我确实生病了。我确实病了。但我也觉得，我知道它们会去哪。我觉得第一次约会的焦虑确实在其中发挥了作用，但她当时是真的生病了。我是真的生病了。我有抗生素处方可以证明这一点。
Backdated. I'm like, hey, duck, I need a favour. So I didn't go. And then, like, I just, we were talking for a bit. And then I kind of just, like, didn't reply to the last message. And then I talked about a week. And I was like, uh, uh, and then I just sent a message. I was like, how I'm going to be in the city.
倒填日期的。我就像，嘿，鸭子，我需要一个忙。所以我没去。然后，我们就聊了一会儿。接着我有点……就没回复最后一条消息。然后我大概过了一周才联系。我说，呃，呃，然后我发了一条消息。我说，我待会儿要在城里。
Let me know if you want to join me for a drink. And he was like, absolutely I would. And I was like, and then from that point, it was just like we were dating. Yeah. But I think that's the thing though is that it, that whole cliche of, oh, when you stop looking, Sam-a-Mu-Khan. You're never not looking for love. I just think that's bullshit.
如果你想和我一起喝一杯，告诉我一声。然后他说：“我绝对愿意。”我就想：从那以后，我们就开始约会了。是的。但我觉得关键在于，那个陈词滥调——“当你停止寻找时，萨姆-阿-穆-卡（Sam-a-Mu-Khan）。”你永远不会停止寻找爱。我觉得这纯属放屁。
I think the thing is, though, is that you can't be looking for a relationship for the sake to tick a box because you're setting yourself up for failure and you're literally going to settle for the first dud that like sniffs in your direction, which isn't. good. So you need to be at that point where you're happy with yourself and I think that's where Al finally was. Like she'd done all that work, cut off that dead weight and was like lost to 80 kilos. Exactly. And then that opportunity presented itself because she was ready and I feel like my little teenage self was also the same. But even though I was like, no, I'm ready for a boyfriend now. Like, where is he?
不过我认为关键在于，你不能为了打勾而寻找恋爱关系，因为你是在为失败做准备，你实际上会妥协，接受任何一个在你身边嗅来嗅去的废柴，这可不好。所以你需要达到那个状态，即你对自己感到满意，我觉得阿尔最终就是那个状态。她做了所有那些工作，切断了死沉的负担，然后就像减掉了80公斤。没错。然后那个机会就出现了，因为她已经准备好了，我觉得我年轻的小女孩时期也是如此。尽管当时我还在想：“不，我现在已经准备好找个男朋友了。他在哪儿呢？”
But by that point, I knew what I did and didn't want out of a boyfriend, even just by the shitty people that I'd interacted with as a young woman. Yeah, but that's the thing. Like, you can't be looking for a relationship to make up for something that's missing in your life. Like, you should have everything your cup should be literally overflowing. And then that overflow, you can give to a relationship. That is such a beautiful metaphor. I didn't make it up. I heard it somewhere.
但在那个时候，仅仅通过我作为一个年轻女性与糟糕的人交往的经历，我就已经知道我从男朋友身上想要什么和不想要什么了。是的，但事实就是这样。你不能为了弥补生命中缺失的东西而去寻找恋爱关系。就像你应该拥有一切一样，你的杯子字面意思应该溢出来。然后凭借那种溢出的部分，你可以给予一段感情。这真是一个美丽的隐喻。这不是我编的。我是在哪里听说的。
But it's a good line. I didn't want to coin it and someone be like, copyright. But it is an analogy that I heard. I can't remember where, but that you or you can give to other people, your cup should remain full and you give others the overflow. Yeah. Because they should be filling up your cup too. So that way that's, yeah.
但这是一句很好的台词。我不想把它据为己有，免得有人觉得是版权问题。但这是一个我听过的类比。我不记得在哪里听过的了，但你或者你可以给予其他人，你的杯子应该保持满满的，而你把溢出的部分给予他人。是的。因为他们也应该把你的杯子填满。所以这样才是对的，是的。
It's a give and give. I don't like the give and take. Everything's a given give and give. And, you know, the whole point of this episode is like, how do you maintain your identity in a relationship? You've kind of talked about what you both do in that sense. What would you do if you realize that you were losing yourself? What would be like the antidote? What would be your solution if you woke up and you were like, all right, actually, there's some stuff that I've, that's flown under the radar a little bit here that's actually become a bigger issue.
这是一个互相付出的过程。我不喜欢那种斤斤计较的关系。一切都是彼此真诚的付出。你知道的，这期节目的核心就是：如何在亲密关系中保持自我？你们俩刚才已经探讨过彼此在这方面的做法。如果你发现自己正在迷失自我，你会怎么做？有什么解药吗？如果你有一天醒来发现，好吧，其实有些被我忽略的小问题，现在已经变成大问题了，你的解决方案是什么？
Not suggesting that you break up with your partners, but like in terms of. of like what would be some of the things you would immediately put in place or get back to? I think the first thing is don't panic. I think don't have a knee joke reaction and panic and think, oh my God, I'm a completely different human being. Who am I? Because it is a scary thought to feel like maybe you've lost that power over yourself and it is a bit intimidating.
并不是说建议你跟伴侣分手，而是说，有哪些事情是你愿意立刻去执行或重新开始的？我觉得第一件事就是不要慌乱。不要有膝跳反应般惊慌失措，然后觉得，天哪，我变成了一个完全不同的人。我是谁？因为那种感觉——觉得自己可能失去了对自我的掌控——确实挺吓人的，也让人有点无所适从。
But I think it's good to simplify where that's coming from within yourself and really take kind of everything away and think what do I want? What is my identity? What are the things that I like doing that make me feel genuine joy? Is that going for a walk and listening to your favorite podcast, the psychology of your 20s and two broke chicks? I was hoping you would say yours as well. I was like, go on. She's in marketing. Is that, you know, calling your friend is that reading your smarty little fairy book, finding out what those things are and doing it and committing to that plan of putting that time in for yourself or whatever that is that your identity is because there's this book, what's the book that I'm obsessed with that I always quotes out, the one about habits.
但我认为，去理清这种情绪的源头是个好方法，把其他杂七杂八的东西都抛开，然后想想：我究竟想要什么？我的个性是什么？有哪些事情是我喜欢做并且能带给我纯粹快乐的？是去散步、听你最喜欢的播客《The Psychology of your 20s》和《Two Broke Chicks》吗？我本来希望你也会提你们自己的播客。当时我想，说呀。她在做市场营销。是那种，你知道的，给朋友打电话，还是读你那本装模作样的奇幻小说？搞清楚这些事情是什么，然后去做，并承诺花时间去重拾这些能体现你个性的事情，无论那具体是什么。因为有这样一本书——我是那本书的狂热粉丝，经常引述它——关于习惯的那本。
Atomic Habits. Atomic habits, that's it. And so his whole theory that he writes in this book about identity and individuality is that it is made up of your habits. Your habits, create who you are. So if you are doing habits that constantly involve someone else, whether that is hanging out with your friends all the time, or it's hanging out with your partner all the time, or it's being at work all the time, there's nothing within those habits that is making you individual because it's coming from other habits that involve other people. So you need to identify the habits that make you who you are and invest time into those again. Because when you were single, you had all the time in the world to do that.
《原子习惯》。对，《原子习惯》，就是这本。他在书中关于个性和独特性的核心理论是：你的个性是由习惯组成的。你的习惯塑造了你是谁。因此，如果你养成的习惯总是涉及另一个人，不管是整天和朋友泡在一起，还是整天和伴侣在一起，亦或是整天待在工作岗位上，那么这些习惯里就没有什么是真正属于你个人的，因为它们都源于涉及其他人的习惯。所以，你需要找出那些能体现你本色的习惯，并重新把时间投入其中。因为当你单身时，你有全世界的时间去这样做。
Whereas when you're in a relationship, your time shifts. And it's so easy. It's so easy to happen. And you're not lesser than for that happening. It happens to everyone. I feel like that's such a normal experience. And I think as well as rebuilding those habits, perhaps exploring new ones. Yeah.
而在恋爱中，你的时间分配会发生变化。这是极其容易发生的事。而且出现这种情况并没什么大不了的。每个人都会经历。我觉得这是一种非常普遍的体验。而且我觉得，除了重建这些习惯之外，或许还可以去探索一些新习惯。对。
Also have the conversation with your partner and be like, hey, like I'm feeling this way. I feel like I need to invest a little bit more time in myself. maybe you can do the same and like communicate that so they're not like wait why are they pulling back what's going on and don't over dramatize it though because i feel like as well that like if your partner comes to you randomly or you go to your partner randomly he's like yeah i feel like i don't know who i am i'm going to spend some time alone i would be like oh is everything okay yeah like you'd be like you know what i really miss going to pilates yeah i'm going to start doing that every sunday morning and like do that and then i think as well with your friends if you've
同时，也要和你的伴侣沟通，比如：嘿，我最近有这种感觉。我觉得我需要花更多时间在自己身上。也许你也可以这样做。把这种想法说出来，这样他们就不会纳闷：等等，他们怎么突然疏远了？到底怎么回事？不过也别把事情搞得太戏剧化，因为我觉得，如果你的伴侣突然来找你，或者你突然去找伴侣说：对啊，我觉得我快不认识自己了，我要花点时间独处。那我可能会想：哦，一切都还好吗？对，你可能会说：你知道吗，我真的很怀念去练普拉提的日子。对，我打算以后每周日早上去。然后就去行动。同时我觉得，如果你和你的朋友们...
you know, let that part of your life slide. The most annoying thing is when a friend either breaks up with their partner or they realize that they've lost themselves. And then they're like, hey, I'm back. And they sort of just like expect everything to go back to normal. If they've completely ditched you, that can be like a really frustrating feeling. But what I've had in the past is people say, hey, like, I've realized that I've been spending a lot of time with my partner.
你知道的，让生活中的那部分疏远了。最烦人的情况就是，当一个朋友跟伴侣分手了，或者他们意识到自己失去了自我，然后他们突然说：嘿，我回来了。并且他们理所当然地觉得一切应该回到从前。如果他们之前完全把你冷落了，这真的会让人感到很沮丧。但我过去遇到过的情况是，有人会说：嘿，我意识到自己最近把所有时间都花在伴侣身上了，
and no one else. I'm so sorry. I just completely lost side of everything else, but I really want to put effort into this friendship. That's such a beautiful way. Can we catch out? And I was like, I so respect that honesty and that introspection. And then it didn't even give me the chance to be like,
而忽略了其他人。真的很抱歉。我把其他所有事情都抛到脑后了，但我真的很想好好维系这段友情。这真的是一种很棒的方式。我们能见个面吗？当时我就觉得，我太尊重这种坦诚和反思了。甚至都没给我机会去想……
well, look, go again, growling back. Because I'm like, she knows. Thank you. And thank you for acknowledging and not like brushing it under the rug. Yeah. And yes, let's go get coffee. Yeah, I love you. That's a beautiful.
好吧，你看，又摆起架子了。因为我想：她心里清楚。谢谢你。谢谢你的坦承，而不是把事情轻描淡写地掩盖过去。对，没错，我们去喝咖啡吧。对，我爱你。这太美好了。
You're my best friend. Yeah. I had that happen and it was, I think it's also one of those things where you can't expect that, like you said, for everything to be the same. I've like had that in the past where a friend has moved in with someone. She moved in really quickly within like seven months. They were super in love. Two years later on, we hadn't heard from her for like a year. And suddenly she was a wreck because this was her entire identity. It had fallen apart. And she came back and was like, okay, so why aren't we doing the same things anymore? They broke up. She was like, Why aren't we going out drinking all the time? Why aren't we hanging out in each other's houses? And I was like, because we all have jobs now. And because we all have partners now and because we're all doing different things. But I think she was really, she eventually came around to that realization and was like, I actually just really need some help.
你是我的好朋友。对。我经历过这种事，我觉得这也是那种你不能理所当然地认为——就像你说的——一切都会一成不变的情况。我过去遇到过这样的事，有个朋友和别人同居了。她搬进去的速度极快，大概才七个月。他们爱得火热。两年后，我们有整整一年没听到她的消息。突然之间她崩溃了，因为那个人就是她的全部世界。当这一切破裂时，她回来了，然后说：好吧，为什么我们不能像以前一样做那些事了？他们分手了。她说：为什么我们不能老是出去喝酒？为什么我们不能经常泡在彼此家里？而我说：因为我们现在都有工作了。因为我们现在都有伴侣了，而且我们都在过着各自不同的生活。但我觉得她最终还是想通了，并且意识到：其实我真的需要一些帮助。
And we were like, yeah, of course. Like we'll do what we can. So guys, I think this is all we have time for. But this has been an amazing episode. I really want to ask. Both of you. This is something that the girls do on their show, Two Brokechik's life lesson,
然后我们说：当然可以，我们会尽力而为。好了各位，今天的节目时间差不多了。但这真是一期精彩的节目。我真的很想问你们两个。这是《Two Broke Chicks》在她们的节目中经常做的一个环节——生活小贴士，
but what would be your life lesson from this conversation that you would like to instill to someone who may be questioning whether their relationship is getting in the way of their own identity? I think the biggest life lesson is for this, for me, would be a reminder that, like, you are so fun to hang out with. Hanging out with yourself is the best time.
那么，从这次的对话中，你最想分享给那些可能正在质疑自己的恋爱关系是否阻碍了自我寻找的人的生活小贴士是什么？我觉得对我来说，最大的生活小贴士就是一个提醒：其实和一个有趣的灵魂相处——那就是你自己。独处是你永远能做的最好的投资。
that you can ever invest in. An investment in yourself is always a good investment. So don't ever feel like you've lost yourself because you're still in there. You're still in there. You might be a little bit different and that's okay. But it's like with any muscle, you just keep doing it and it gets stronger. So if you are feeling like you have lost your identity, don't worry. It's not gone.
对自己投资永远是一笔划算的买卖。所以永远不要觉得你失去了自我，因为你依然在那里。你还在那儿。你可能稍微变了一点点，这没关系。但就像锻炼任何肌肉一样，只要你坚持下去，它就会变得越来越强壮。所以如果你觉得自己失去了自我，别担心。它并没有消失。
It's still in there. Yeah. And there are so many ways to have a relationship, a romantic relationship, and for it to be fulfilling and fun and beautiful, but it doesn't have to take up your entire life. And I think that's a really important reminder to fill up the other cups in your life as well. Yeah. Thank you so much for your brilliant wisdom. Thank you, that. Of course, if you are not listening to Two Broke Chicks, you've just got to do it.
它依然在那里。对。经营恋爱关系有很多种方式，浪漫的恋爱关系完全可以让人感到充实、有趣而美好，但它并不需要占据你的全部生活。我觉得这是一个非常重要的提醒，那就是也要把生活中的其他杯子斟满。非常感谢你们充满智慧的真知灼见。谢谢你，真的。当然，如果你还没听过《Two Broke Chicks》的节目，你真的得去听听。
They're a lot funnier than me. So it's true. Go and listen to them if you're loving Australian accents and you can't get enough of them. Like not these two. And amazing banter and very incredible wisdom. So thank you both for coming on the show. Thank you for having us. And where can they find you personally?
她们比我幽默多了。这是真的。如果你喜欢澳大利亚口音并且百听不厌，就去听她们的节目吧。不像我们俩。而且她们妙语连珠，有着非凡的智慧。非常感谢两位来到我们的节目。谢谢你们邀请我们。大家可以在哪里找到你们呢？
So you can listen to Two Broke Chicks, Wherever Good Podcast Assault. Spotify, Apple Podcasts, we're everywhere. You can't get away from us. Also on Instagram at Two Brokechicks and on TikTok. at Two Brokechicks underscore. That underscore will haunt us for the rest of our lives. Someone else got there first. And it's fair enough.
你可以在各大优质播客平台上收听《Two Broke Chicks》。Spotify、Apple Podcasts，我们无处不在。你们逃不出我们的手掌心。还可以在Instagram上关注@Two Brokechicks，以及在TikTok上关注@Two Brokechicks下划线。那个下划线会纠缠我们一辈子。因为被别人抢先注册了。不过这也合理。
Early Bird gets the win. That's true. And if not, you can catch us at Vasco in Surrey Hills every Friday night. Woo! I was outside and a vodka lamb set of waiting for you. Yep. Very lovely. Well, thank you all for listening.
先下手为强。确实。如果不通过网络，你也可以每周五晚上在萨里山的Vasco找到我们。呜呼！我当时在外面，还有一杯伏伏柠檬鸡尾酒在等你。没错。非常棒。谢谢大家的收听。
As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. If you have a friend who needs to hear this episode, send it to them. What a raid though. What I imagine if you send it to your friend who was in a relationship. Yeah.
一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你身边有朋友需要听听这期节目，发给他们吧。不过这算不算一种突袭呢？想象一下，如果你把它发给正处在恋爱中的朋友。对。
You're saying. Yeah. And no comment. Just like just a link. Yeah. Nothing else. And you know what? Maybe they'll thank you later.
你懂的。对。而且不加任何评论。就只是……发个链接。对。什么都不说。你知道吗？也许他们以后会感谢你的。
Probably not at that point in time. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
不过在当时那个节骨眼上可能不会。一如既往，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养适应力的科学。
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在回顾一档播客节目中。对于1979年来说，那对我是一个重大时刻。1984对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。
On the Look Back at a Podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集 我们都会挑选一个年份 剖析当时发生了什么
And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild year
并试着去理解我们是如何在朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家（比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔）的陪伴下度过那段时期的。关于80年代 那是一个疯狂的年代。
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts
我认为 对于黑人来说 没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Hey what's good y'all You're listening And learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《Learn The Hard Way》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而这一切都是在一位知深专业持证心理专家的陪伴下进行的。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct?
有多少男人披着一副重型铠甲？这向世界传递出一个信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn The Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你捏造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped.
我捏造了一次检测报告。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。真人真事保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。